every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'll be fine without me
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalists podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less
my name is Joshua fields Millburn and
what you're about to hear is a live
version of our podcast which Ryan and I
recorded in our beautiful hometown
Dayton Ohio now this was a very special
event for us because while we were able
to fill up the same theatre my favorite
theatre in the world actually the neon
theatre in downtown Dayton it's the the
same theatre that I used to live two
blocks from well until we moved out to
Montana actually now as most of you know
Ryan and I have been taking a bit of a
pseudo break from podcasting personally
I've been resting a lot and working on
my health which I talked about in
episode number 30 which is titled away
and Ryan has been overseas visiting all
of Europe with his partner Mariah
thankfully during this break we were
able to publish so many regular versions
of our podcast which we recorded
on the road during our minimalism
documentary tour this summer we visited
15 cities during that tour and including
the Dayton podcast you're about to hear
we have published six of those live
episodes and this Staton podcast is
likely the last episode we'll publish
from that tour because the other nine
cities yielded either poor audio quality
which was our fault or sometimes there
were issues at particular theaters or
some of the other ones that just had
really similar answers because the
questions were identical that's great
we're all asking similar questions and
so the the problem with that is we're
not going to publish duplicate episodes
into into our stream which means that
this will be our last podcast episode
for about the next month which makes
October the perfect month for you to go
back and catch up on these past 35
podcast episodes from the minimalists
podcast
don't worry I do have good news for you
Ryan and I and of course our fearless
producer Sean well we will be back next
month in November with brand new in
studio podcasts including timely
episodes on gift giving holiday
minimalism mental focus and much much
more
so make sure you subscribe on iTunes or
wherever that you get your podcast so
you don't miss any of those forthcoming
episodes but first before the live
Dayton podcast I have three exciting
updates for you
number one minimalism all over after a
outstanding theatrical run as the number
1 indie documentary of 2016 minimalism a
documentary about the important things
is finally available digitally on iTunes
and Amazon and Google Play as well as on
on Vimeo and also even on DVD so you can
check out the trailer to the film and
find links to all of those platforms
over at minimalism film.com and if you
enjoy the film we really hope that
you'll be willing to leave a review on
whatever platform you buy it on those
reviews really help us out and they help
us reach more people because it shows up
in those algorithms and and then of
course the film gets recommended to more
people and they get exposed to this
concept of minimalism
alright update number 2 the last writing
workshop of 2016 well if you want to
improve your writing whether its
business emails or blogging or maybe you
want to write your first book I'd like
to help I'm hosting this year's a final
how to write better one day online
workshop which is basically just a
stripped-down version of my four-week
class I'm hosting that in just a few
weeks the workshop is alive but it's
also recorded so don't worry if you
can't attend the live class because
you'll still be able to watch the
workshop at your convenience and rewatch
it at your convenience and also have
access to all of the links and resources
from that workshop you can find all the
details to that workshop and my writing
class over at how to write better org oh
and fYI seats are limited for the
one day workshop so you can still get in
though there are still seats left
number three final update for you a
Florida Meetup
I'm gonna be back in Florida in October
and so if you're nearby I would love to
see you at our free Meetup on Tuesday
October 11th at 7 p.m. as many of you
know Ryan and I began 2016 this year by
opening a well curated coffee house and
community gathering space called bandit
coffee Co with with a few of our friends
down in st. Petersburg Florida by the
way if you'd like to see a photo tour of
that coffee shop you can just go to the
minimalists comm slash coffee house
we'll also put that in and the show
notes for you anyway much has happened
since we opened that shop at the
beginning of this year the theatrical
release of our documentary sold out
North American tour a handful of charity
events which have been grade the online
release of our documentary which just
happened and of course our our keynote
talked over at TEDx Fargo you can find
that on our YouTube channel and so it
feels right to sort of book end this
year this beautiful beautiful year it
has been with a casual meetup at the
same coffee shop that kicked off the
year so my final public appearance of
2016 is going to be happening this month
at banded coffee you can join me and the
folks from the local minimalist dot or
meetup group for a free meet up again
that date is Tuesday October 11th at 7
p.m. Eastern I I will give a brief talk
personally I'll answer your questions of
course dish out hugs and even make time
for a group discussion you can RSVP for
this event which is free but you can
find the RSVP links over at the
minimalists comm slash florida just
heads up on this one space - that one is
limited it's a big shop but it's not
that big that we can fit hundreds of
people in there so you'll want to get
there early and if Ryan is in town which
he might be then he'll be at the event -
okay those are all the updates for now I
hope you enjoyed this version of the
minimalist podcast and my favorite city
in the world
the birthplace of aviation 100 spoke
gold rims and of course the minimalists
my hometown Dayton Ohio and stay tuned
after the podcast for some minimalism
tips from our listeners and if you have
a minimalism tip or if you have a
question especially you have a question
about gift-giving or the holiday season
and you give us a call at four zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine
we'll see you soon until next time take
it simple well hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast live edition
from Dayton Ohio
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and that makes us the
minimalists and we're here to answer
your questions today we're gonna start
off I don't know how much time we have
so we're gonna start with three
questions the first three people who
ever want to come up and and ask your
question on this microphone we'll be
happy to answer them the good news is my
favorite pedagogical technique is if I
don't have an answer to your question I
will just ask a or I'll answer a
different question so you can ask
whatever you want just say your name and
whatever your question is like you're
passionate about traveling though right
okay ah okay yeah yeah Dayton is a great
place to live I looked through the first
31 years of my life or within the area
at least yeah it's it's really gonna be
very self specific for you where you
want to live I could tell you the reason
Ryan and I moved out to Montana when we
first so we were living here and and we
had been on our first book tour we went
to 33 cities over the course of like a
year and at the very end we
we were driving back to Dayton from
Vancouver BC and we knew we had to drive
through this long state called Montana
and we were kind of dreading it cuz
we're just excited to get back home and
get back into the the routine of what we
had established and you know what it was
the most beautiful place I've ever been
and like we just knew like driving
through there we've got to come back out
here at least for something so we
decided to move out there for four
months to write a book a book called
everything that remains and we found
ourselves gravitating toward this so we
live in a cabin on the side of a
mountain when we did that in the middle
of Montana winter which you wake up and
it's like negative 28 degrees outside
and chopping firewood when it's that
cold is just as fun as it sounds and we
decided to move to Missoula after that
because we found ourselves gravitating
toward it and and it was it's kind of
like Yellow Springs but in a bunch of
mountains and a little bit bigger and it
was it was a great community a lot of
culture per capita and I think
ultimately you have to ask yourself what
are my values and and Ryan and I wrote
about this in our first book a book
called minimalism live a meaningful life
we know it starts with the stuff getting
the stuff out of the way but that's not
the end game that's simply the first
step and so by getting rid of the excess
stuff it allowed us to identify well
what's actually important in my life and
the five areas that we came up with of
health relationships passion growth
contribution and the the place where I
live needs to allow me to to serve all
of those needs and here's the thing that
will change over time and having access
to certain things will change over time
in fact I think one of the best places
to be a a minimalist is often in a
bigger city we don't live in a big city
now especially but having access to what
you value most and so I think you're
gonna have to identify ultimately what
are my values and can I find that can I
serve those values in Grand Rapids or in
Dayton Ohio or in Missoula Montana or
Los Angeles
and and instead of work from there yeah
I think the good news is is you don't
have to choose indefinitely right I mean
I would certainly encourage you to
explore more if you haven't found that
place that like makes your heart feel
that way like man I got to come back to
this place then keep exploring man um I
can tell you from me when we started
traveling when we did that that tour
like every city we went to we go to
Chicago and I'm like oh my god I want to
move to Chicago and then we go to like
Portland I'm like oh my god I wanted to
Portland and then San Francisco like oh
my god I wanna be San Francisco and and
I felt that with that way about a lot of
places but but coming through Missoula
and the way that I just felt how the
community was it just felt like a
community that was very rich in culture
and just to give you an idea of how rich
it is in culture I was there when we so
we moved from the cabin in the middle of
nowhere to Missoula and I was when we
were in Missoula for no less than two
weeks I had like somehow accidentally
landed this like main role in this play
just from kind of just kind of meeting
other people and I'm like this is the
only stinkin city where something like
that could happen never acted a day in
my life and and Here I am like leading
this play so that that's what made me do
it
I'll tell you too like the only other
place I felt that was awesome as
Missoula was it was Maui and like I
never like had the expectation to move
there or you know to spend the rest of
my days there but I do remember how Maui
made me feel when I was lucky enough to
go there several several years ago and
and yeah that's kind of the feeling that
I look for man that's what really drew
me back to Missoula so I would encourage
you to keep looking and and commit to
something eventually if that's if you
want to settle down you know commit try
it out and it sounds like you you live a
life that allows you to kind of be that
that a peripatetic person and you can
you can absolutely move on if it doesn't
work out for you man yeah and you can
always come back to I could say every
time I come back to Dayton like I want
to move back immediately
I had lunch at I nine today I had coffee
over Apress I used to live two blocks
from from this theater
and it's one of my favorite theaters if
not my favorite theater in the country
and I just always come here and watch
matinees and stuff it's just it's a
great community here and so I think it's
a nice thing you make a decision it's
not a permanent decision you do want to
commit to it you want to find a
community embed yourself in that but you
can also move on you can also graduate
on to something else and it's not like I
I got divorced from Dayton I just
graduated from it and you can always go
back at some point thanks guys I travel
to get here in my body and I couldn't
find an air B&B so if anyone wants to
host us I'd be great thing I bet you'll
find someone out there thanks brother
howdy the question I have have you guys
considered targeting an edge not
targeting educating the younger people
yeah it's funny you mentioned that uh in
DC there is this like little
eight-year-old girl who went up to Sean
afterwards and she's like can you please
ask Ryan to write a children's book on
minimalism and yeah I think it's a great
idea I would love to go around to
schools and speak or high schools even
but yeah certainly you know I hate to
like use the cliche of like the children
are our future but they certainly are
man and I do think that this is a very
important lesson for people to start
learning at the youngest you know as
young as they can kind of grasp it
certainly I am open to ideas that you
have on how to make minimalism appealing
to kids I have been like kind of
outlining some stories that I think
might resonate with children but you
know it's it's uh I know that if I was
five years old and someone was telling
me like get rid of your stuff like I I
don't know how well I would grasp onto
that at five years old but certainly if
there's a way that we can do that we
will certainly do that I mean we do a
lot of speaking stuff now and Josh and I
we were very deliberate with our time so
we check we choose one big project
pretty much every year so you know this
year it was this year and last year
actually was a documentary 2014 was our
one hundred city tour so we don't we
don't get our plates too full of stuff
so
you know we don't want to dilute all of
our efforts we try to avoid that as much
as possible um if I do decide to do that
I mean that is something that it would
be something we would have to commit to
for that entire year and right now we
are just focused on kind of getting this
out
getting this message out the best way we
can and using any vehicle necessary I
mean for the longest time we were just
writing essays and writing books well I
saw sunny you know a year or two ago
that said the 49% of males don't read in
the United States don't read books don't
read books REI it's half the males
aren't illiterate right they just thank
you for clarifying yeah so so yeah it's
really awesome that we can make a
documentary now I mean I can't tell you
how many people have either you know
found us through someone recommending
like I'll go see that documentary so
this is like their first introduction to
this whole concept or we started that
podcast back in December and and yet
people found us to that medium as well I
think I was a Chicago Chicago Tribune
who called this they were like man this
is really cool multimedia project you
guys have going on and that's kind of
how I look at it right now it's like we
are going to continue to use as many
vehicles as possible to get this out
there to continue to build on this
foundation that we already have but my
mind is absolutely in line with what
you're talking about for sure I agree
and I'm really encouraged by the the
number of kids who is starting to show
up at our events and especially in 2014
in Omaha we had a thirteen-year-old kid
his name was Ethan and I'm talking to
him and his mom afterward and and I was
like hey did your mom drag you out here
was it okay and he's he's like no I
brought her and and what I've learned is
that it's great that we can educate the
kids and we should work on that because
that's the ideal time to instill proper
values and help people uncover what
their their values are but but also you
know we can be educated by by our kids
as well and and sort of relearn the
appropriate behaviors and relearn
creativity creativity and imagination
and we can learn from
them I think just as much as they can
learn from us and so at our events we're
seeing a lot of a lot of high school and
college kids show up we're seeing also
we had a 92 year old great-grandmother
show up in San Diego actually she was in
the film in one of the hugging lines and
so so you're kind of seeing everything
in between but I would love to find a
great effective way to communicate to a
the masses of children because I think
it's important thank you thank you
hey there yes this is one of our former
co-workers he's he's like one one of the
few people who like you know stuck
around and supported us there there's
there's a quite a few of them I should
say but but yeah so thanks for sticking
sticking through this with us man the
question that I have for you is you guys
clearly are able to establish a message
and are connecting to people in the
masses the question I have is when you
are being interviewed by the people in
sedation the people in PR do you really
feel like that message is adding value
which you've always always is that
message bringing value to those
individuals and are they then becoming
champions for you guys the people in the
media it kind of depends you you all
solve a guy who was like good luck with
that
he couldn't even bother to like say
goodbye to us I don't know if you
noticed that and it was it was real
shitty because it was 5 a.m. in
Albuquerque and and I'm like we're out
there trying to spread this message and
I can tell you a lot of the time I'll
have some of the most meaningful
conversations I have are with some media
folks who are like they get it because
they're just like everyone else they
just happen to be in in this this media
position that allows them to have a
platform but but they also get it but
there are other people who don't and and
that was the big thing for us is we
weren't out there trying to convert
anyone especially these media people
yeah we all want to be liked I want
people to like me for sure but it's not
the reason that I do this it's just like
happiness isn't the reason I do this
it's to live a more meaningful life and
part of that is contributing beyond
myself and so those media media outlets
they're just a platform to communicate a
message and if the if they can also be
messengers it's even better and I find
it depends on the outlet like there's
some NPR stations who have replayed the
interviews we've done with them you know
a dozen times and and that's really nice
there other times we go on and
everyone's polite and we move on and
hopefully it got out to some people but
I think it really depends on the
individual yeah I would regardless
whether or not you know the people
interviewing us or buying into it or not
I really appreciate the fact that we
have the opportunity to kind of spread
this in a public way and that stations
are at least open to having us on there
because when we first started you know
getting these interviews I was really
shocked like wow like they're gonna be
like all right here's Josh and Ryan the
minimalists after this commercial break
it kind of you know it's kind of a weird
juxtaposition going on there but but the
fact that they're even willing to have
us on there and start this conversation
it certainly yeah opens the the people
who are interviewing opens their hearts
and then the callers that we have who
are getting introduced to this it's
certainly opening their hearts as well
so yeah I mean we'll continue to do as
much as we can it's not like we don't
have our critics
I remember The Globe and Mail which is
like Canada's version of The Wall Street
Journal basically The Globe and Mail
they
I got an email about this piece and it
was an opinion piece and and and within
the first paragraph said well I just
read a book by but two guys who left
their wives and moved into a cabin
together after getting rid of all of
their stuff and they just totally didn't
get it and and I think what I've learned
a lot about a lot of a lot of that
criticism the especially the criticism
isn't valid I'm happy to take valid
criticism or I mean the Chicago Tribune
just did a review of the film and it had
had some criticism in there that you
know while I don't necessarily agree
with it I think it was it was it
articulated well and I'm willing to at
least consider it but most most of the
time that we judge others it's just a
mirror that reflects the insecurities of
the person who's doing the judging and
so if I'm saying you know man that
jacket sure looks bad on you Travis
really what I'm no what I'm really
saying is is you know what my personal
preferences are and what my own
insecurities are and and I'm projecting
that onto someone else and and I think
that's that ends up being what most
criticism is also where we've developed
into a culture of outrage we love to be
outraged now at anything and you know I
just don't pay attention to that anymore
III don't let that get me down because I
feel like we're doing we're doing
something important and and if you're
gonna criticize it that's fine I mean
the opposite of that would be us not do
anything at all and that's how we cannot
be criticized and so yeah I'm happy that
when we do get the platforms to to
communicate to communicate message
really believe in but yeah I'm not
trying to convert anyone there thanks
for coming out brother appreciate it
I love how you talked about how how from
when he remembers you in the corporate
world teaching adding value yeah like
that's one thing that had transferred
over from the corporate world it was
like we'd be in our meetings and Josh
would be like alright how are you guys
adding value to your customers and yeah
that's great out that some of that stuff
definitely transfers over well I think
that's that that's important because you
know it's not like there was anything
inherently wrong with working in the
corporate world it's just where I was no
longer aligned with my values and my
beliefs my interest my desires the
person I wanted to be and and so I had
to to let go of that to move on to find
the person I wanted to be you know it's
not that I wasn't focused on what was
important I got to a point where I
didn't know what was important in my
life and so I had to start asking
tougher questions and for me it started
with the stuff do these things add value
to my life and the truth is some of
those things did add immense value to my
life but the vast majority of it the
things I'd worked so hard to accumulate
over all of my 20s most of those things
didn't matter at all and so I stored
them away in boxes and bins and had a
very organized life but really I was
just a well organized hoarder and so you
know the average American household has
300 thousand items in a three hundred
thousand right and and I certainly had
that and I did a good job of hiding it
with my boxes and bins and everything
else but but the truth is that those
things got in the way the pursuit of
things got in the way of the pursuit of
meaning in my life and and I had to
change that and so by letting go I made
room for my health I made room for the
people closest to me
I made a room for what was meaningful so
before we close it out tonight we will
be will be out there afterward well
we'll set up we we just have a hugging
line we also have some books out there
if you do pick one up we ask that you
minimize it afterward but if you don't
have any money with you today or you
didn't bring your wallet or whatever
don't worry you can pick up a book on us
we definitely want you to have one but
yeah just let someone else get value
from it after you've you've read it the
the experience is meaningful not the
artifact itself and we'll be out there
make sure you grab a hug as well I wanna
I want to say thanks to a few people
first off Jonathan and his whole team
here at the neon like I said my favorite
theater in the country I just wanna say
thank you to them they are awesome and
the man behind the mission the guy who
helps us with everything he's the
producer on her podcast our road manager
our tour manager he edits our books he
does pretty much everything behind the
scenes he's the hardest-working man in
minimalism
ladies and gentlemen Sean Harding right
here we could not do this without Sean
he just adds tremendous value to
everything that we do so we're really
grateful for you thank you
I also we so we're on the road for one
month this year we learned our lesson
doing the hundred city tour right we we
were not gonna do that again but we
donated a year of our lives and learned
a lot from that so we're on the road for
12 and a half cities this month and it's
really expensive to go out and travel
even though we we do it as cheaply as
possible with Airbnb Xand and stuff like
that but we had started that blog six
years ago and we couldn't even spell
blow okay at the time and we've had we
have a great hosting company a place
called Bluehost that hosts our site but
we also reached out to them and asked
them if they'd be willing to help us
financially on the tour and they said
yes they they didn't want anything from
it but I just want to say thanks to them
so they're helping pay for some of our
travels during this tour and I want to
give them a round of applause thank you
so much
and if you leave here with one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for your time
we'll see you out there
hey Joshua Ryan is Kevin from Orlando
Florida
I just really wanted to leave a tip for
the tip on top of another tip that I
heard on your podcast I'm a runner
Solingen I knew
countless half marathons I've done one
marathon and numerous 5k and at each one
of these races they always give you most
of the time you get a medal and you also
get a t-shirt for that race so after
doing so many of these races and runs
shirts just pile on the top pile of
shirt and I've I've taken on this
minimalist lifestyle
I took my closet and I counted all my
hangers and had 123 hangers at one point
so now I'm only down to 30 hangers to
take 10 of those hangers and those are
for my everyday clothes and the rest I
use for my race shirt that I like and
then when I go to another race let's
pick up another shirt that means one of
those shirts that is on one of those
hangers if I want to keep this new shirt
has to go and keeping just those hangers
keeps me from buying more shirts or
collecting shirts or hanging onto things
and then another ship they also do is I
serve a hanger Lobster direction then
within 30 days if that in hanger hasn't
been flipped back around then that
shirts got to go obviously I haven't
needed it in the last 30 days so why do
I need to keep it do a magic example and
animage and Houston Texas a new
minimalism then I hadn't experienced
yesterday that I thought could bring
values by their family I was at lunch
with a friend and our two young
daughters one two moms walk up with
their
offering the prices they want in the
crane machine to our kids I know how
hard it is to balance minimalism and
children so I rented a great total at
the kids have experience of playing the
game without holding on to the stuff
that comes with it means someone else a
chance to enjoy it but I'll definitely
be using this in the future and I
thought it could help others so Josh and
Ryan it's Connor Franta I'm 17 and I'm a
patient grade 11 right now so exams are
coming up in my mental clutter is coming
to all-time high right now so I use
something to help me focus on setting
and writing that I recently started
using and it's an app called comodoro
timer so that's p om o de oro it's a
really simple timer app and based on a
kitchen timer that uses a Productivity
practice called the Pomodoro Technique
it's a time management method that's
used to break down work into intervals
traditionally 25 minutes of concentrated
work separated by short five-minute
breaks so after a number of cycles
reward yourself with a long break that's
usually 15 minutes and on the app you
can adjust the duration of the work
sessions and breaks you can decide daily
targets and you can even count along
with your progress over time so I found
it that over time I've been working more
productively and getting more out of my
study sessions and I hope you could find
value in that too Thanks
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me
every little thing that you gotta hang
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tear your eyes
you